[Music]
how you doing people this is the reuben
report i'm the new ebola czar dave rubin
and i have two guys with great names i
said it last time
they were on together and they still
have great names alonzo doraleo max
lugabeer
are with me and i feel i feel a heady
smart intellectually savvy show
so let's get right to it so of course
isis released the beheading video of
journalist alan henning earlier this
month
now it sounds like there may be another
beheading today
today is wednesday and at the end of the
alan henning video they promised to
behead american journalist peter kasich
so we'll see if they if that happens but
interestingly yesterday
video was released of what appears to be
american aid that was supposed to be
dropped for the kurds
to fight isis but surprise surprise it
ended up in isis's hands let's take a
look
foreign
okay so that hasn't been independently
confirmed so it's a little unclear when
exactly that was dropped some people are
saying
some of the stuff may be from somewhere
else but it's clear that a lot of it is
american made
we got a huge situation going on on the
turkish syrian border in the town kobani
which is where the kurds are fighting
isis the turks are kind of fighting the
kurds
everyone's just fighting everybody we're
sort of bombing people we don't know
what the hell is going on
it's a big freaking mess ben rhodes
who's the white house press secretary
he commented earlier this week about
dropping aid and who it's getting to
we feel very confident that we've been
able to hit the target
in terms of reaching the people we want
to reach what i can assure people is
that when we are delivering aid now we
focus it on the people we want to
receive
that assistance those are civilians in
need those are forces that we're aligned
with in the fight against isil
and we take precautions to make sure
that it's not falling into the wrong
hands
and then there's the video that you just
saw so you look every week we do
something about isis and it's a big
freaking mess and i feel like we're
we're
aiding the wrong people half the time we
don't know who our allies are people are
helping us they're not helping us
so does any of this surprise you in any
way well you know this is this goes back
to the whole thing where
you had the hawks the hawk republicans
in congress were like oh
we're going to support the right syrian
rebels and not the wrong syrian rebels
and
yeah of course this stuff's gonna wind
up in the wrong hands i mean you know we
armed al qaeda to fight the russians and
then
face our own guns ourselves this is a
history of this stuff yeah so it's just
obvious like we see these videos like i
saw the video immediately i was like of
course
this just is so sad bad homeland episode
or something
yeah it's it's definitely it seems like
the the sort of early healthcare.gov of
military operations i mean i can't
believe
but there's like there's people doubters
online saying that this is like a
falsified
video right yeah well of course there's
all the conspiracy theorists and if you
go to infowars.com
what's his name who's the guy at
infowars uh alex
alex jones babbling on about all the
conspiracies and is the cia really isis
and all that stuff
i don't know what the hell is going on
but what i when i see these videos
it makes me realize how important the
social media game is like how much do
you think that that really you know
we've discussed
can we show these videos how much of the
beheading stuff should be shown twitter
isn't posting them anymore
how important do you think the social
media game is to both sides well you
know i mean obviously the
the game has changed it's not like where
you know uh osama bin laden would send
his new videotape to the networks and
they hope they would show it now it's
you've got everybody's got a direct
conduit and so
yeah four guys out of a job well you
know the guy
the the press uh liaison for al-qaeda
yeah so sadly
no and so yeah i mean i think that we've
seen it work in both directions you know
it can bring to light something like the
uh you know the the tareer square
protests or whatever but at the same
time yeah these guys can use it
and i'm sure while twitter's trying to
crack down on it and i think people are
starting to realize how maybe i
shouldn't share the beheading video on
my facebook
wall it's still going to be going around
and they they are
they've got a direct link to people that
they didn't have before yeah they're
using it to recruit too
sure yeah it's scary is this the
inherent problem with sort of doing a
half war
i've been against this thing from the
beginning we didn't get congressional
authority to go to war in syria
it was still unclear whether we had that
to even do anything in iraq anymore but
we don't even talk about that anymore um
but is this part of it when you just
when you just do airstrikes as opposed
to doing more not that i'm saying we
should do more
that this is good what's going to happen
because you're going to bomb people and
just drop things as as opposed
to having things on the ground where you
can literally hand
weapons to people or hand food to people
etcetera
you think that would be capable of more
accuracy what with like drone technology
and stuff like
that right he's driving which is not
that good we're always afraid of drones
or they're just
not that great it's crazy to me that we
can put a robot
on mars and yet we can't accurately drop
ammunition where it needs to be
yeah um final thought on this do you
think the military
industrial complex actually cares where
the weapons end up because that's the
other thing i started thinking like ah
you know what they dropped those well
that just means they have to drop more
for the other guys
so it's like the machine just keeps it
if they could arm both sides they would
that's where the money is pretty sure
that's totally yeah scary thought
yeah i don't think there's any qualms on
any part about this yeah
all right well that is a scary thought
to end that with so uh take
what you will with that all right let's
move on uh some more isis stuff so there
was a 17 year old
from australia who has now become a new
isis spokesman
this is crazy there's been this
fascination uh with westerners
that are becoming spokesmen for isis and
joining the movement so we've got some
video
this message i deliver to you the people
of america
i deliver this message to you the people
of britain and i deliver this message to
you especially the people of australia
and i say this about your coalition you
threaten us with this coalition of
countries
bring every nation that you wish to us
bring every nation that you want to come
and fight us
it means nothing to us whether it's 50
nations or 50 000 nations
it means nothing to us bring your planes
bring everything you want
to us because it will not harm us why
because we have allah azzawajal
and this is something that you do not
have to the leaders
to obama the tony abbott i say this
these weapons that we have these
soldiers we will not stop
fighting we will not put down our
weapons until we reach your lands
until we take the head of every tyrant
and until the black flag
is flying high in every single land
until we put the black flag
on top of buckingham palace until we put
the black flag
on top of the white house we will not
stop and we will keep on fighting
and we will fight you and we will defeat
you
allah
okay so abc news is reporting that he is
abdullah
elmir who went missing from west sydney
about four months ago i mean he's got a
crew he's got a posse they're into what
he's saying
um black flag on top of buckingham
palace and the white house
so again we were just talking about the
uh
propaganda element of this whole thing
how fearful should we be about these
people like that is kind of scary a room
full of these people and knowing that
he's coming from the west
and leading this thing i never liked pep
rallies
um i will say that i think the the
propaganda war is something that we
could be waging better in the middle
east i think that
it has become so easy to sort of portray
the west in america as the great satan
or whatever
and it might help us to maybe counteract
that to some extent and
you know not make it so easy for these
guys to recruit
you know these kind of wide-eyed easily
impressionable young people
um you know i'm i'm a big fan of uh
you know the marshall plan you know i'm
all about let's show up with butter and
not just guns
yeah and i think that there there are
things we could be doing in the middle
east
to sort of rebrand the united states as
the people who are constantly putting
boots on sacred soil right so i'm with
you and i used to do a bit about this in
my stand-up act like give these people a
playstation
and they might have something else to do
as opposed to bombing them nobody has
their house drop on them and then thinks
you know i love these guys
um does this sort of show how desperate
isis is in a way
that they keep pushing this stuff out
like that the fear factor with that
thing is bigger than what actually
maybe they're accomplishing on the
ground well i mean i think it definitely
like
makes people uncomfortable the idea that
you know
nationals with foreign passports could
be converted to this like jesus camp for
psychopaths
and you know are out there like clean
you know saying these things i think
it's uh it's definitely a scary thing
you know they're they're preying on
these like desperate people you know and
they're just indoctrinating i think it's
it's it's really terrifying so what is
desperate about this because i'm
fascinated by this thing where these
westerners
and often a lot of the ones especially
from england they're they're middle
class some of them are upper middle
class some of them from france
also uh so they're not that desperate in
the way we think of desperate like that
they're destitute or homeless
and nowhere else to turn a lot of them
are middle class people
kids i mean 16 17 year olds so what is
it about this thing that's appealing to
me talking to a 17 year old who just
found jesus
i mean come on yeah no the the you know
fanaticism knows no
socioeconomic level and so if you have
people who are
dissatisfied with their life or their
parents or whatever
and you know you can it's easy to push
them into any kind of movement that
claims to have all the answers
that makes them feel important uh and it
just so happens that the one that these
guys have latched on to is isis
right and uh that's what's happening
right now i mean i i think that you
you see similar activities from similar
disaffected youth you know in all kinds
of places just the other ones aren't
carrying guns and posting videos on
youtube
yeah i guess maybe at 16 17 i was
thinking more about sex and drugs and
video games and basketball that i don't
know that something like this where they
would have taken all those things away
from me
would have appealed to me so i don't
know that's the part that i'm having
like i get your point
but that's the part that i can't really
get around so what appeals to these guys
about
not having these freedoms that's the
part you were saying a lot of them are
upper middle class i think that for a
lot of people who have been raised
in you know relative comfort and luxury
if you can
sell them on a a sort of
radical fundamentalist fill in the blank
religious path
then that's that that's a means of
rebellion and that's
oh all of my cushy stuff is terrible and
how dare you give this to me parents
and you know that that's as much of a
weapon as anything else yeah i guess i'm
pro
cushy stuff i feel like you're you're
pro we're all pro
no one's joining isis around my first
thought when i watched the video was
that it was jonah from tonga you know
the chris
lilly show i mean yeah same accent same
disenfranchised sort of i feel like we
could learn a lot from that show get
this guy a rap contract i think
he might have something there um do you
think that these people that go
that leave countries like australia and
france in the us and britain everything
should be allowed to come back that's
the
debate right now in congress although
congress isn't really working but that
seems to be a debate right now should we
allow these
people to leave and then come back into
the country i don't think it's that
uh crazy to say no if you go fight for
isis
you have to give up your past i think i
think we send kerry from homeland to
turn them
and turn again they become double agents
yeah otherwise yeah no forget it
would you let these people back in i
mean all these countries are debating
this should these people be allowed to
come back i don't even
see how that's a debate i mean if
there's like
evidence that they've bought into a
psychopathic uh
murderous terrorist ideology like you
know like isil i think uh
no passport revoked if you've threatened
the head of your own government
um then i'd say pretty much that's
you've thrown your passport on the
ground and spit on it that's
that's kind of how that works right wing
nut bags here on the reuben report this
week
okay let's move on uh you're not going
to believe this but
americans do not trust the media the
media is doing such a good job all the
time
people don't trust them i don't know why
pew research came out with a poll
uh which news organizations are
trustworthy and not trustworthy let's
take a look
so believe it or not cnn the most
trusted name and news that's what they
tell us they are
they are the most trusted according to
pooh 54
uh of respondents believe that uh cnn is
trustworthy only 20
said untrustworthy and then you know you
see the the other big networks abc nbc
cbs all kind of hovering around the 50
to 46
area then the cable news ones jump in a
little bit less
i thought the one that was interesting
here fox news 44 msnbc
38 so i guess it depends uh who you like
as to who you trust
new york times down at 34 and then some
of the other interesting ones daily show
you know everyone says the young people
get their information from the daily
show but only 16
of these respondents said they trust the
daily show 15
for colbert uh hannity and limbaugh not
doing well 12
they're screaming all the time and
they're not doing that well uh drudge
report
only eight percent uh and then finally i
want to stop with buzzfeed only two
percent
i get a lot of stories from buzzfeed for
this show at this point and i
generally think they're pretty good it's
only two percent
they're they're like the hip cool thing
now they're even partnered with cnn
who's number one on this list so
buzzfeed told me that the gilmore girls
character i was
was sookie and clearly i'm gypsy
so i don't trust them anymore that that
does make sense
so it's those self-reported polls what
is the demographic that was pulled
because you know i think that's
something that's important you know what
if they were pulling all
sort of older people you know and
obviously older people don't watch or
trust the daily show as much as you know
millennials but
um yeah it's interesting that cnn would
be the most trusted yet it always comes
in second or third in relation to fox in
terms of
viewership yeah people have a weird
thing with cnn right like i feel like
everyone want the reason i make fun of
cnn so much is because i want it to be
better you know what i mean like we all
know what fox news is on the right and
we know what msnbc is on the left
so i when i when i watch television i
want to trust
something so then when they do all the
ridiculous plain coverage or just the
endless 24-hour news cycle when they
have nothing to report on then they say
we're not going to speculate and they
spend the next hour speculating i always
want them to be better
i think that's partly what's going on
here people say well i trust them but
it's just i trust them the most
out of all these others it's successful
branding i think people like the idea of
cnn
more than they like cnn more than they
watch cnn yeah uh and so i think there's
this idea of it being kind of the way
people used to think of the new york
times as the paper of record you know
the gray lady
you know i think cnn has that kind of
like
bayer aspirin brand trustworthiness
even though people are actually buying
the you know the generic because it's
cheaper
yeah yeah i agree what do you guys make
of the fact that all the digital stuff
is
so low so buzzfeed that we talked about
but all of them i mean huffpo
tyt wasn't even on there i mean why is
it that all this stuff
is so low because to me it seems like
online is like is actually the last
bastion
where you can get some some freedom and
some honesty
and yet people are still reporting that
yeah i think that's the problem with
digital media it's that like everybody
is just looking for
you know everybody's just all these like
publishing organizations like buzzfeed
huffington post they're just
pumping out clickbait more and more and
uh i think that compromises the quality
of the reporting
yeah and again i would i think you're
going on your point from before i'd like
to see who
got this poll who did you ask because
uh you know if yeah if they're 25 to 38
or
higher than that then yeah they're not
watching the other show they're not
going to be getting news online
but i'd say younger certainly are you
should do a poll on
trustworthy polls sure that would be
that would give us some
something there how do you guys decide
who to trust i mention this every week
that i don't know what to trust anymore
who to trust
oh i go to all these sites i watch all
these news things
and usually by the end of any report i'm
thinking that was half [ __ ]
every art you know how do you decide who
uh to get your news from in a way that
makes sense to you you know sadly like
most people i think i probably just
whatever
whatever matches my you know the bias
that i
brought into it in the first place you
know much like any fox news watcher just
it's a different bias
yeah yeah i tend to um like if i'm
interested in a topic i'll look at its
wikipedia for one to get a 30 000 foot
sort of broad
gist of what's going on uh and then i
spend a lot of time on google
yeah try to form my own hypothesis of
whatever that issue is yeah um but again
like i go to cnn.com i think cnn is
is great again you know i think that
they're they're already awesome i think
their potential is
is limitless do you guys think that the
biggest problem we have in america is
the failure of the media you know we
talk about money in politics political
time and i know all this stuff is
interconnected and our politicians are
all bought and nobody's
honest and blah blah blah but that the
media has just utterly failed us so we
don't even have an informed public
to have the proper debates which maybe
explains why these numbers are also
terrible
we lost ben bradley this week you know
who is one of the great
bastions of of you know journalism at
its peak in this country or one of its
zeniths um yeah i mean i think obviously
the corporatization of news the fact
that you know what what network
told us 30 years ago over 40 years ago
you know about how
when news and entertainment combine when
news has to get ratings when news has to
sell advertising
then yeah that then it becomes another
show and
um you know i think given that you know
when you look at
what does rupert murdoch own and what
does you know these very small handfuls
of people
who control a great deal of the mass
media
uh obviously there's going to be a
filtration process where
you know i wonder sometimes even i love
rachel maddow on msnbc and i think is
she really going to tell me about
ge you know of course and all the
contracts that they have with military
things
and you know it never started answering
the problem when you ask people what it
is that they want they'll usually say
vegetables but if you watch them quietly
they'll go for the candy instead and i
think that people just need to be more
sort of proactive and vocal about the
kind of news that they want
yeah well said good ending on that one
all right so yes we all agree
cable news is absolutely terrible and
it's hard to decide who is the worst on
cable news
but the washington free beacon put
together this little compilation
of al sharpton and take it away i don't
think it's divided at all
it's not divided at all make some
friends
make some friends we're the party of
equality
the party of equality u.s policy has
changed
u.s policy has changed we are seeing at
the same time
liberty under assault liberty is under
assault
the democrats are feeling the heat
democrats
are feeling the heat i didn't expect
that that was going to be
my lifetime's work he didn't expect it
to be his lifetime's work
i think that will be the demise of our
republic the demise of our republic
i'm not forgiving ducks and deer weapons
to shoot back at me
giving ducks and dear weapons to shoot
back
at you what does that even mean
i think they're cooking the books on
this cooking the books
in the way of the people's priorities
the people's
priorities nor do i recall anyone
believing that
he doesn't recall anyone believing that
thank you for your question thank you
for your question
we have a weak and indecisive president
that invites impression
the president invites aggression it
would be a dream come true
a dream come true it's time to move
beyond this
it's time to move beyond this a trained
eight could get a status of force and
screaming
a trained ape really really
really really really really really
okay wow that is i mean that goes on and
on
uh al sharpton is just absolutely
terrible but he's just one of the many
on cable news that are absolutely
terrible he might be the worst
so let's just start there i mean we were
all cracking up as we were watching that
how is that even how does her producer
sit there with him and yeah please see i
blame the producer on this i
think the producers and the writers like
they though that worked once
yeah and they oh let's do that thing
where he says the last four words as a
question
i don't know that i blame al sharpton on
this one wow just because i think for
the most part i think
generally a lot of the talking heads on
cable news are just reading the monitor
oh of course they're just reading the
monitor but you know what if it's your
name on the show then
uh i know you know like i'm hello he's
innocent and all this but i'm just
saying he did not work alone
regardless that clip wins the internet
like i have to thank you it's like
that's the funniest thing i've seen in a
while
who do you is there anyone off the top
of your head on any of the networks that
you can think is worse because
i watch him everywhere anyone on fox
almost anywhere let's not get crazy here
yeah so who do you like then that's a
more controversial topic than who sucks
we can agree that pretty much they're
all terrible
i got a couple that i think are pretty
decent i'm going to hold them in my
pocket
again i like rachel maddow a lot um i
like
melissa harris-perry um
i like chris hayes on saturday and
sunday morning more than i like him on
weeknights
i don't know what that's about but
that's just a thing i have trouble
watching because he seems like a little
kid and they just put glasses on to make
him look smart but i know he's a nice
guy
he and ezra klein and marcus melissa's
all look like the
sharpest minds on the eighth grade
debate team i don't know what it is
about those guys they are
so perpetually dewy yeah i'll give props
to one guy on cnn jake tapper i actually
think
is a good reporter and he does it good
in the studio and then he goes out in
the in the field and does it
um but do we give too much credit for
all these people and i say that with all
do
whatever because i'm sitting here we're
online but i'm doing the same the same
thing but do we put too much stock in
that they really at the end of the day
are just entertainers more than
we more than reporters we've sort of got
that they're not really reporters right
right yeah i think that their job is to
make
uh you know the perception that there is
a commotion because that's what draws
viewers you know
yeah where it just sort of like it
activates our amygdala which is like our
emotional center the fear center of the
brain
um because that's what people that's
what you know it's not good for us so
much but it's good for ratings
yeah so why do some people just terrible
people
just stick around like someone like al
sharpton who's been terrible for like 30
years and has done so much awful [ __ ]
um and and is so biased and clearly not
a good broadcaster why do terrible
people just
stay around you know people don't
disagree what is it the peter principle
right though everyone rises to the level
of their own incompetence i don't know i
mean
why you know why is lindsey graham still
a seated congressman you know why
why there's it's amazing the people who
have failed to the top and
certainly cable news isn't any different
i think that i'm sure their
q ratings are good they probably test
market well or they focus group or
whatever they
you know they they solidly hit their
demo of you know
39 year old uh denture wearing
retired you know some things i don't
know all right you got me i just feel
like when the cameras are rolling the
last thing you want to be is
tepid and benign especially on tv when
you know money
time is money yeah so well i do think
that has a lot to do with it that you're
not going to get
measured people that are going to show
both sides because yes then huffington
post doesn't write about what they say
and everybody wants click so then that
that inherently kind of destroys the
truth
but we're not done with uh cable news
just yet so fox news had a clip
this is a 10 second clip and i think
that this pretty much sums up
everything that you need to know about
cable news uh we got this from media i
take a look
like a card trick that you've seen ten
times
in colorado is that real that is real
max that is real
uh i feel bad for the closed captioners
at moments
like forget it i mean okay
that is just awful so you're seeing the
head of the dnc your head the head of
the rnc
and they're just let's just watch it
again can we just watch it again
like a card trick
i i don't know look i do a show like
that i i have done this now i don't know
how many times we've done this 50
we've done this i don't know 80 shows or
something a lot of clips are up there
like i've been able to manage so that
people aren't just
now again i don't have that
um is that partly that because they
just are doing talking points right
debbie wasserman wasserman schultz is
doing talking points rinse priebus is
doing talking about so because of that
that inherently makes them just talk
instead of listening there's no
listening going on at that table right
now no one ever answers the question
they're asked they just they come
pre-loaded with whatever it is they
wanted to say the ben affleck
you know thing on bill maher that you
did a brilliant job in
dissecting we'll link to that thing
right there it was brilliant brilliant
is part of this also just the way we are
wired that really we are wired for
controversy you were talking about this
a little bit in the previous segment
but that we have a left brain and a
right brain so it's like we can only
sort of deal with two talking points so
the more extreme that they are the more
it sort of fits
into the way we can comprehend things
because it leads to
it basically takes the onus off of us
for having to do our own thinking you
know when we have people that have a
perspective and can sort of like lead
the pack so to speak
it also is very you know our already
sort of overworked amygdala is the fear
center of the brain i think it
uh it definitely appeals to that sort of
tendency to be alarmed that fight or
flight uh
you know mechanism that we have and so
um i think that's why that's why people
gravitate towards those sorts of clips
well like you were saying i think a lot
of the cable hosts are less
journalists now than they are sort of ed
sullivan you know instead of like here's
the beatles and here's to
you you know like here's ebola and
here's benghazi it's like it's all about
not enough to bore you i'm going to keep
you entertained and keep throwing things
at you
that are going to excite you and if you
don't like this one you'll like the next
one yeah
do you guys think that the average
viewer realizes that that's actually not
news that that's purely propaganda if
you put up the head of one party
and the head of another party and then
just have them uh
babylon that stuff that's written right
in front of them that that's actually
not news people watch at fox news sunday
it sounds like it's a news program
but all you're doing is just handing out
propaganda on both sides and then
because
they they give two points of view
everyone thinks it's equal right
yeah that the idea first of all yeah
that's that's been one of the great
things you talk about why why does the
news terrible now this idea of parody
that
that you know okay because we're talking
to this rational sensible person about
global warming we now also have to talk
about this
oil company shill to make sure that
we're being equal you know and then
there's never any analysis after this
happens constantly i see this even with
anderson cooper who everyone loves
they'll do that exact thing so it's you
got the scientist
for global warming then you got this oil
guy and then they both spout their thing
and then he's like all right and we're
going to commercial
but it's like no we got to now analyze
what did we just see
worst about that that guy couldn't
improv his way out of a wet paper bag
let's just watch the clip one more time
trick that you've seen ten times
democrats
all right i love this story and i think
this is going to be right in alonzo's
wheelhouse comic alliance
put together a list of the superhero
movies a timeline
of the superhero movies for the next six
years that's going to get us to 2020 and
there are a
boatload of superhero movies coming out
let's take a look
okay so in 2014 we actually only have
one more we've only got a couple months
of the year left big hero 6 which i'm
told alonzo my people tell me you saw
already i did
even though it's not out yet yes is
there anything you want to hint us
about it i liked it you like it go read
my review with the wrap
okay there you go uh so yeah 2015 we're
going to get the next avengers then
ant-man
fantastic four now interestingly
fantastic for the comic book they just
announced that the comic book is dying
or dead or they're killing it in like a
month or something uh deadpool batman
superman
next uh captain america another x-men
etcetera etcetera then we got wonder
woman in 2017 another wolverine they've
done like 87 of those
uh sinister six which i think is going
to be an offshoot of spider-man if i'm
not mistaken
uh fantastic 4-2 in 2017. uh then we'll
jump we'll just skip ahead then we got
there justice
i mean it just goes on and on you guys
can all look at this yourself venom's
getting his own that's another
spider-man
oh shoot lego batman i guess from the
lego movies he
people liked him right then i like this
one marvel in may
of 2018 is just doing unknown movie and
then they're following it up in july
with another unknown movie and then
another one in july another unknown but
is at least going to be in the x-men
universe um so obviously uh yeah you've
got to own that weekend early yeah you
have to
just put just uh i'm putting a peg on
the calendar and
i don't know what it is yet but it's
going to be a thing yeah everybody else
stay away
so as as a movie guy when you see this
now i i
generally love all these movies a couple
of them you know i'll see and i
don't really like the the fantastic four
that they're now rebooting i didn't like
the original two
um but pretty much i i like all these um
i have liked more of these movies than i
have not like yeah for the most part i'm
you know i grew up reading comic books
i'm not averse to oh
comic book movie superheroes but when
you see it all listed out like that yeah
i i have to admit
part of me as a film creator thinks
you know it's like because nobody ever
sat down and said like here is every
romantic comedy you're going to see for
the next five years you know
that nobody plans that kind of thing but
boy just the idea of all of those
sequels and
read threads and i mean like they're
rebooting green lantern in 2020 i guess
that'll be
a long enough time for the stench of the
ryan reynolds one to go away
which i didn't hate um yeah so you know
yeah
i look they're making money i there's a
real there was a really interesting
piece in the l.a times recently about
how the reason that the potato famine
happened in ireland
was because they were a one crop economy
and when that one crop fails you are
[ __ ]
yeah and hollywood has become a one crop
economy and that's it that's the crop
and they're making movies and now and
those movies are making money now but
when they stop making money
then what okay so i'm totally glad you
brought that up because it seems to me
that this is all we can create
anymore in america we lost all our
manufacturing jobs right we don't have
much
we're not creating much but one thing we
can do and that we still do basically
well
is the blockbuster ruby so the studios
sort of have to do this right
because they can sell it in china yeah
speaking of selling in china
transformers for i did my review on it i
saw your review on it
can we make sure that michael bay does
not how do we do this how do we set it
up
again his movies keep making money so
there's nothing really good trailers
that was there was a good trailer
that's all his movies are they're
three-hour trailers disaster um where do
you where do you fall on these superhero
movies
i love yeah i'm with you guys i love
superhero movies i'm excited that dc is
getting some more love these days
uh and yeah i think i mean i tend to
prefer when they are a little more
serious in nature like the dark knight
siri the trilogy is still like one of my
favorite things that's ever been made
um but yeah i you know it is weird
seeing them all sort of laid out like
that but i think that like the
the big franchise nature you know of
hollywood you know investing so much
into the
you know sort of tried and true also
kind of paves the way for more
sort of unique films i feel like i mean
this was a really good year for film we
had gone girl which was awesome
boyhood which we were talking about
before um and then
birdman which i just saw which was
amazing yeah um
and even within the framework of these
things i mean guardians of the galaxy
who would have thought that that was
going to be like a comic book that not a
lot even comic book nerds are like wait
which one was that one you know
so they're they're at least thinking
like okay we have this brand we have
a fairly built-in audience we can maybe
play with this a little bit
and so if they continue to do that then
that's exciting and that that has
possibilities
um you know and and i think that uh i i
would be maybe
a little more excited about the dc stuff
if zack snyder weren't directing
so many of them but that's neither here
nor there um but no i mean it's here or
there
it might be both for this conversation
but you know these are these aren't
characters that have worked and that
for a lot of people have a lot of
meaning and and could be
turned into something really fun but i
just worry that there's so
much of it in such a concentrated period
of time that they're daring us to get
sick of it basically
is there to just play devil's advocate
on that is there possibly because of the
way the studios are doing this and the
way that they're laying this out in
advance
uh that they're able to make the worlds
much bigger i mean that seems to be what
they're doing they're
you know they give you a little plot
point so in spider-man 2 for example you
already had the plot
of that the sinister six were already
coming so there is
some foresight which is nice as opposed
to just throwing out one movie and then
trying to figure out a sequel that
really just
you know well yeah i mean i think you
know i i bet if marvel had its druthers
they would own all of their characters
but for a long time they were licensing
them out here and there
and so you had like a daredevil movie
that had nothing to do with the
spider-man movie they had nothing to do
the next one we did anything with a
fantastic four movie so
now they're sort of approached this is
really going back to the 60s and the
marvel universe when it was originally
created
the idea that there would be this
interlocking continuity of all this
stuff even dc kind of
followed marvel's you know lead on that
one um
and so yeah if they want to expand out
the cinematic universe and have the
avengers
meet the guardians of the galaxy and
have doctor strange meet spiderman
whatever
sure you know i i again i mean there's
certainly potential there but there's
also the potential to just
if we have to see another goddamn origin
story that we're all going to shoot
ourselves in the face right
like i get it he was bit by a
radioactive spider you got to show me
another way
what does it say about us that comic
books are dying while this stuff is
blowing up that's just like
uh you know things are changing what are
you gonna do they're on paper
like is that but you know you get them
on ipad now i'm sure i think it's just
that like people crave myth and it
doesn't matter the medium it's just that
like
for today the way you know stories you
know
the the amazing way in which stories are
now able to be told in cinema i think
has sort of displaced
you know our attention you know our our
necessity for comics which i think is
like sad but um
it's definitely and comic books have
been dying for 40 years you know i mean
you look at the numbers they were
getting in the 60s even like a romance
comic
which is back when they were actually
gearing comic books to you know female
readers
um you know giant numbers and then
uh over time you know yeah the the
movies get bigger and you had your
superman movie and your batman stuff
whatever
but the numbers are constantly shrinking
you know you'll occasionally get some
cult item like you know frank miller
doing the dark knight or watchman or
something
and then you know there was that awful
period in the 90s where they became
beanie babies and everybody was
buying up foil embossed number one issue
that
then became useless because everybody
owned them and they weren't worth
nothing
yeah um so i mean it's constantly been
in the numbers have always been in
decline
but they i think you know i it would be
nice if these movies would
drive some traffic to the comic book
store i don't know that necessarily is
happening but
at least it's keeping the publishers
alive the the money they're making off
of these movies right
all right well thank you guys for taking
a little time from your busy superhero
movie scheduled
to tune in with us all right let's move
on i really like this story so this was
on uh yahoo they are saying that
wearable technology like the apple watch
it's gonna have its day we know its day
is coming
uh the apple watch is coming in january
and that this type of stuff is gonna
you know stick around for a little while
but that ultimately this is all going
to the technology being embedded in us
so they had an interesting article that
we're going to link to right down below
with nine technologies that are going to
be part
of our human body and we're going to go
through a couple of them uh right now
the first implantable smartphone yeah
that looks a little scary hopefully
they're going to get it to the place
where it's not going to be that
obvious but scientists are working on
eye implants that let an image be
captured with the blink
and transmitted to any local storage
images might be displayed through
artificial skin in your eye implants all
right so hopefully
you're not going to have a giant patch
of discolored skin on your arm but i
guess getting the phone actually
embedded into us at this point it kind
of seems obvious doesn't it like the
watch to me
almost seems ridiculous at this point
because it's going to do less than the
thing we have in our pocket
um so just putting the phone in us it's
coming right
yeah i mean i don't think it's a bad
thing i mean think about the degree to
which we've bonded psychologically with
our technology i mean we haven't yet
bonded physically but we will it's
coming and i think that
uh you know it's i think only good
stuff is going to come of that it's
going to allow us to measure
you know an amazing an infinite number
of you know biometric qualities which we
can then use to improve
um so i'm excited for the health
implications for sure well i'm going to
get to my robots are taking over
later but i know you're you're going
positive to start the next one
cyber pills that will talk to your
doctor a british research team is
developing cyber pills with
microprocessors
that can text doctors directly from
inside your body so basically you'll
have these things inside of you and if
there's something wrong
with one of your organs or something the
doctors will find out immediately that
that seems pretty good right
technology can kind of help with with
the health stuff right as long as my
cyber pill doesn't get spammed
i get a lot of calls on my cell phone
offering me carpet cleaning and you know
virus protections yeah cyber you're down
with this this help your you're into the
medical stuff
yeah i mean i i've been lately obsessed
with the microbiome have you guys heard
of that it's basically the universe of
microorganisms that live in your gut
that outnumber your own cells
ten to one and there it's got so many
implications on our health outcomes that
um it's just like mind-blowing and we're
just at the very tip of the iceberg in
terms of like understanding the
interplay between that
and our health wait does this have
something to do with the the poop thing
that everybody's talking about it does
have something to do with that
we got to do a story on that can you
break it down in like two sentences yeah
so basically put someone else's
yeah so there's there's a bacterial
infection that kills i think 14 000
people in the u.s yearly for which there
is no
cure and they found that they found a
cure and that cure
is really gross fecal transplants yeah
yeah and it's it's a very rudimentary
way of tinkering with the microbiome of
these people that have these kinds of
infections by basically replacing
what they have going on with a help with
the microbiome of a healthy person
and so this is what it looks like today
and five years from now it's not gonna
be
that it's gonna be like specific you
know bacteria that can then help
um but again we're at the very sort of
beginning of all this stuff and i think
having you know those kinds of
you know smart pills that you can
swallow and analyze what's going on in
your intestines i think that's like
that's really cool yeah all right let's
move on to smart tattoos
researchers have crafted an implantable
skin mesh of computer fibers thinner
than a human hair
that can monitor your body's inner
workings from the surface a chip has
been made that
can be embedded in a finger through a
tattoo-like process
letting you unlock things or enter code
simply by pointing
so i thought this one was kind of
interesting because just this week apple
pay
was released and this is just what
you're gonna do on your phone but soon
enough
it's gonna be your finger so we all saw
this coming right once they started with
the touch id
that was just the one step for your
fingerprint and then apple pay so the
next thing is just the talk
now muggers will be cutting your hand
off that's great
well in minority report remember they
had to take the eye out
i mean yes it all makes sense right i
mean just think about like the iwatch
that's something that we've got to
actually like strap on our wrists
that tattoo could potentially make it
something that we have on on us all the
time
yeah so all right let's move on uh smart
dust full computers each much smaller
than a grain of sand
that can organize themselves inside the
body into as needed networks to power a
whole range of complex
internal processes with smart dust
doctors will be able to act inside your
body
without opening you up this one's going
a little bit over my head
i just sort of kept picturing like those
scenes in the matrix where you just see
the matrix like create
something am i how often am i on this
one you got anything
uh i mean this is the dawn of the
nanotech revolution right like we're
going to be able to materialize things
from thin air we're doing it sort of
with 3d printing i mean it's a very sort
of rudimentary form but
um i think it's you know it's just it's
basically capitalizing on the fact that
technology is becoming infinitely
smaller
faster and cheaper and so eventually
we'll be able to like inhale
smart robots that repair cellular diet
things like that i mean
okay it's nice that you're excited about
this very exciting
i have two issues one aren't our cell
phones already giving us all cancer
like i mean do we really want one
actually inside of our body now
don't worry i've got all the bad things
at the end i'm just playing along with
that and then the other thing being of
course is that people are already
walking into traffic
looking at this crap like now they're
gonna be staring at their arm i mean i
just i don't know
well they won't be serious because their
eyes will be replaced with something
that we'll
see you'll see there you have it because
we'll be watching traffic is the problem
my point here
is i don't know i just i i for one feel
like i i always want to embrace the idea
of what people call the technology
shabbat
you know where they take one day of the
week where they turn off all their
screens and they don't go online and
they don't check their texts
that's smart and i can't do it i would
like to but i haven't gotten there yet
but i mean
once it's in you you're that there's
there is no shabbat ever like
it is you are constantly connected yeah
don't eat ham on that day also
uh one more for you the verified self
uh the us military has serious programs
to equip soldiers with implanted rfid
chips
so keeping track of troops becomes
automatic and worldwide
this technology could be used to id
every single human being
uh so this one doesn't seem that uh off
to me i mean i could see this obviously
there's military purposes
but now let's get to some of the scary
stuff so then we already have this whole
big brother thing in the nsa thing so
now we are going to be walking around
with the stuff where we'll be able to be
id'd all the time
they will be able to track us all the
time it's not just going to be the
device it's going to be built in us
so as someone that loves technology and
i love all this stuff too but i always
for what i watch a lot of sci-fi movies
so i always
veer to that place where something is
going to go wrong with it
can you give me some comfort in all this
stuff i mean i think that there are
always going to be speed bumps and
hiccups on the way to you know radical
transformation
but um you know i mean look at the
fappening you know that was a
that was a horrible thing that happened
to these you know starlets due to them
having crazy
amounts of personal information on their
phones right but oh the
yes yes it took me a second to figure
out what we were talking about all the
all the celebrities that got there naked
the fapping got it okay
i mean that was that was an awful thing
but i think that because of that we're
gonna have
enhanced algorithms better security
features so uh
i'm just imagining the cd david
cronenberg back alley operations where
people have to get their little
doohickey removed so they can't be
followed by the cops and
maybe replace with a dead person so that
they you know are off the grid now
see you've watched as many cycles this
is all like existence that's happening
here we all have
ports in the back of our spine or
whatever you know
yeah this just gives me the creeps and
and what's hilarious is you know if you
go back and watch the first charlie's
angels movie
the the the big bad guy's plan is that
he's gonna have a program
that will be able to track everyone on
earth by their cell phone
that's happening right now yeah do you
guys hear that there is a drone
right above us right now because they
know where i just think that life is so
much more colorful thanks to the
the cognitive prosthetics that we
already have that are
in our pockets you know yeah and any i
don't know
the more advanced and efficient they can
become and the more that we can
integrate them in a meaningful way i
think the better
all right there you have it so
technology is coming and hopefully
we can use it for some good but of
course there's going to be some bad so
let's not freak out how was that i gave
us a decent
awesome that was a decent amount of
tumors
all right one more for you i thought
this was really really cool there is a
kickstarter
to create the hoverboard of course
everyone knows the hoverboard from back
to the future too
and they are actually making it let's
take a look
it's real
[Music]
okay so the hoverboard is gonna work
using magnets much like a japanese
bullet train
uh we should tell you though it's not
gonna work on all surfaces so much like
when marty mcfly went over the water and
it stopped working uh yeah they're gonna
have to be special parks
for this to be used and they have a
mock-up of one of the parks so it just
looks really cool
i just like the story just because i
loved back to the future i loved back to
the future too
i haven't liked back to the future three
i know that's controversial but i liked
it
um so i i just love these kinds of
stories um are we gonna have hoverboards
soon when can i get one i would
ride the [ __ ] out of one i mean they
look really fun i think calling them
hoverboards is a bit of a stretch
because you need
it's more of like a maglev thing right
then you need the special sort of
metallic
uh substrate on which to ride it um but
it looks fun
yeah is there something uh is there
something else from a movie that you
wish existed for me that's the one from
my childhood like i remember everybody
talking about that
you know i guess you want the time
machine would be nice sure but if you
can't have the time machine the
hoverboard is there something else
i think the transporter from star trek
transport that would be a good one
that would be good because coach sucks
if i get stuck in another american
airlines seat like i every time i think
oh it's
max when can he look forward to finding
a transporter uh man
five years exponential growth gonna hold
you to that yeah
i'm way too fat for the hoverboard
that's not happening personal injury
attorneys everywhere are
very excited i'm sure about the
invention of this thing yeah uh
what do you think is there something
from a movie that uh the tricorder
the uh but we're almost there right
we're just talking about wearable
technology
that thing that's able to like analyze
health problems that you have just by
like scanning you what movie are we
talking about oh so that's
that's been in a bunch of movies so it
was in star trek it was in uh
what was the one with uh matt damon the
last one elysium it was in elysium
right a couple others it's all about
health with you yeah i mean i'm into it
you know
yeah all right guys that was quick i
just wanted to show you that real quick
because i thought it was really cool
uh follow alonzo and max their twitters
are right down below
and uh barring any sort of uh robot
revolution or anything like that
we'll do this again next week thanks for
watching
[Music]